[Music]
in today's morning rounds the FDA just
approved the first device to treat
attention deficit hyperactivity disorder
or ADHD we first told you yesterday
about the breakthrough that will be
marketed as a treatment for children who
are 7 to 12 years old in now in a
clinical trial kids got low-level
electrical pulses while they slept the
results were similar to the effect of
non stimulant drug treatment an
estimated 6.1 million children have been
diagnosed with ADHD in the US according
to a national survey of children's
health in 2016 our dr. Tara Narula is
here good morning good morning so how
does this work the device is basically a
new treatment that's non drug related
which is great for a lot of parents who
don't want to put their kids on
medication and so it's the size of a
cell phone and basically it has a wire
that attaches to a patch that's placed
on the child's forehead they wear it at
night while they're sleeping for about
eight hours it's meant for kids who are
over the age of seven not on medication
and essentially the way that it works is
it emits a low-level electrical pulse
that essentially stimulates a cranial
nerve called the trigeminal nerve and
the idea is that that nerve then sends
signals into the brain particularly to
the areas that are important for
attention for functioning and behavior
and the idea is that it can help
symptoms and they did see in this small
study of about sixty kids over four
weeks it did reduce symptoms it seems to
be on par with the effects seen with non
stimulant medications so this is the
area of the brain that's still
developing right this is the executive
function right doesn't get fully cooked
until about age 25 what's what's the
downside of it feels like you're
tinkering with a part of the brain
that's developing well this is clearly
the first of its kind and I think
probably we have a long way to go in
terms of the research but as far as this
study they did not see any serious
adverse event they did see side effects
like drowsiness increased appetite some
fatigue headache teeth clenching but as
I said it was a small study and it was
over a short period of time
and we don't know what it would be like
if kids were on medication when they use
this how do you know the difference
between a child that's a little
rambunctious a little distracted a
little hyper and somebody that has ADHD
I think there's a lot of confusion about
what exactly this is so in some kids you
are I think we've got some issues there
they go no that's just their personality
right so we're talking about grace Henry
right a lot of the symptoms like
daydreaming or fidgeting we're really
talking a lot could be misconstrued but
really this is a chronic disorder
affects about 10% of children and it's
characterized by three things
hyperactivity impulsivity and
inattention and the important thing that
is that it's pervasive so you see it at
school and at home it persists for
longer than six months and they can
control and it affects function that's
really if their function is limited
academically socially emotionally that's
when you might you know want your child
to be seen in evaluate then they may in
fact have this we know that a third of
these kids have other disorders like
anxiety disorders or mood disorders 1/3
will go on to carry the symptoms into
adulthood and the issue is that it
really can be associated with things
like increased risk of substance abuse
injuries either accidental or
intentional poor self-esteem poor
academic performance so important to
identify it really truly identified and
get kids treated for it when do you have
it do you always have it some people may
outgrow it and some people as I said it
can persist into adulthood for sure and
there are treatments you know we know
for kids under 6 the recommendation is
behavioral therapy and this is really
where we teach parents how to kind of
reinforce positive behaviors and
eliminate those ones that are negative
and also then medication in combination
with behavioral therapy for kids over 6
the class of drugs we typically use our
stimulants like ritalin or adderall but
as but important for this discussion a
lot of parents don't want to put their
kids on these drugs because they have
side effects to things like anorexia or
poor growth or even cardiovascular side
effects not to pathologize it there's
help out there
yes doctors want to help therapists so
there's always checked with your doctor
yes thank you dr. taryn and we'll always
good to have you here